why so we're stuck in Dallas one I'm
stuck with PC James oh it's worse places
to be stuck is that all right I've
invented a game inside the world of prey
okay have you been here you were saying
Eve not so I didn't actually come in
this room like ten and a half I was into
pray I think it was because the door was
locked and I didn't have the key card
and I didn't have hacking the key card
was here I don't think I came here so
why I missed it
hi so this is the ballistics lab mmm
this is what sort of sphere and it's got
mimics stuck in there
oh poor guys this is where I learned
about the recycle charges if you take
those you see I learned about the
recycle charge by accidentally recycling
myself I got a trophy for it so it's a
heavy distress ichael yourself so if you
hit a release recycle charge mmm these
poor boys all right beat at a bad time
oh but you get some sweet sweet like
resources out of them yeah so my
challenge is you have five minutes
mm-hmm to put as much stuff in here as
you can and recycle it you're five
minutes after five minutes up you have
to put grenade in the grenade container
hit recycle hit G for grenade yeah GG
foreign aid but the person with the most
resources wins okay all resources mean
the same we're just gonna add them all
up the highest number wins okay makes
sense mats all right so who's going
first you're gonna go first
I'm gonna give you controllers that's
what you've been using like a scrubber
is going to start from the second you
hit
the open by an operator button and it
will end after five minutes and then you
have to go and pour granadan cool ready
all right go
come on
Oh God was something so boopy boopy
boopy boopy boopy boopy babe oh my god
it's really difficult to actually just
like uh incidentally so dave was like
i'm gonna look at my phone so I don't
see your strat I just looked over at him
he's just straight a screen watching I
was gonna use this Illinois to buy it oh
no I was like this is gonna set me apart
from Lucy James I'm just gonna empty my
damn it venturi today oh damn it
well alright I'm not gonna tell you what
else I've done we've got both at the
same character though so you've got the
strength to whatever it's called you can
lift moderately heavy stuff alright
you're gonna get in that bin like
hahahaha after the straight do as my bin
gun okay a smug Ben I don't see my bit
huh Mason on the x on the on the clock
how long have I got
that's right off it is yeah June not
doing well oh yeah bet he got one box in
there she's getting around the bits
attack yeah
oh hello I'm just remembered it get out
damn it I was gonna grab ya ha ha ha
come on Amy come on Amy my stratts
before I even have a chance to utilize
it I've played this game longer than you
have me I put strategy you haven't even
dreamed you've never been to this roof I
haven't been in this roof come on Amy
what happens if you recycle recycled
goods oh no whoa Amy Schmidt's going
nuts are you sure you get in there why
are you trying to Sullivan as long as
most of is in town I'll pull her over
here all right
ok
sometime boxes yeah but like I'm pretty
sure doesn't know oh my god it's all
gone wrong I was hoping you would do
that I didn't know what happened I
didn't know explosive things blew up
frig quick I'm a seller or a left two
minutes 20 seconds okay right it means
back in recoverable it's fine it's fine
uh well sir I'm not gonna hack can't
lift that safe yeah what hacking takes
too long
you're wasting time that you could
adjust about the case full of the goods
in there listen I don't tell you how to
do your job you do it's their idea
actually a lot assists how we work
together back to both tell each other uh
still in the bin
give me them fried hard drives all right
I get that stool put that stool back
where it came from must be so help me so
help me sitter sitting in old Simpsons
Monsters Inc pleb club
who was it which broish Prime Minister
no Prime Minister was it Gordon Brown
ago while in that gate
no like a politician called someone a
player but that microphone was still on
thank you
I was bigoted no there was definitely
played gay as well big gate bigger
gateways am big a bigger gate was gone
bro floodgate was probably just some
game White House of Lords get under here
trash can come on trash cans gonna do
that many resources now no you do
something oh I didn't worry about joke
didn't work
you stuck man thank you left less than a
minute
oh god I'm stuck in it yeah yeah like
calendar whiteboard yeah gonna fit in
damn it I'll get this tubing and this
and this yeah no no yeah Lilly Morris I
don't care 25 seconds oh okay um you
count down five uh oh my god hurry up
Mason I know you're showing me this but
I can't actually see I'm Shirley today
alright fact mean Dave who wasn't going
to screen what to do it
hey you you scream watch me four three
two one
I gather loves you got to get out now oh
[ __ ] yourself that was my girls gonna
push the button now you've made an error
here what because you can't put anything
else in but you've dropped out your
cyclo rubs in there oh so you have to
find them anything that falls out now
it's gonna stab spare parts okay I mean
help me I save again the bottle with you
okay what oh this is like the crystal
bloody maze oh okay oh wait you're very
blocked and baby but I think but God's
sake your babies read yourself oh oh oh
oh just clipping the top Oh help me I
think I'm actually stuck I'm sorry
I know yeah oh no he did not fall out
they were on the floor and okay he not
burn them bug in this hacks oh I can't
lose the materials here yeah
synthetic amy Schmidt is shima BL -
hello cannon - n ik if I really
appreciate it if you see it uh uh ield
I promise Oh guys judge
two blondes come on it's crumpled pear
paper not pear crumble fair not they
like their red and wiry like that
girlfriend Braves hair Oh
you grab it a man here near right night
I'm waiting for all the physics as a
freak out and push everything away wait
for the food's to freak out
well alright okay it's gotta be here
somewhere
EMP banana peel ring oh I just wanted
one too late you later
quick time huh that stools out as well
get out slice slide out all right hey
seal the chamber what stays in that
stools gonna have a nightmare that
stills get chopped in half
Oh mom I still be in it's not colliding
as much that was good oh bloody mimic uh
yeah put your things in there few
portents are difficult drop that you
Don's it oh you oh wait our way I've got
to equip it now you just put them in
there put the grenade put them in the
container ow
press why oh oh hey go and now when you
press the button on the computer screen
release recycle Josh all right sir yep
this is the world's worst lottery didn't
even recycle everything hey I got a
demon though reduce reuse why I got
cheaper this is my safe I open up see
you got what it gets open Jimbo he
recycled most of your stuff I just pick
up everything hold oh I forgot you could
hold it
tapping ass like a chump let's see you
inventory
you can't quite a bit got quite a lot
will tap will tally them up a player
takes control
yeah take a screenshot anyone there got
a whole bloody John haha
just unrecycled gonna recycle gun right
alright go ten points one two one go
alright my EFS
open up open up up and open up open up
open up I'm also gonna dump my inventory
what is the the UI is holding me up
already
oh yeah sure blame the UI now trying
kind of hypnotizing my or dropping stuff
oh they did it yeah my next review town
as well wait how did you have an extra
blue cannon I didn't you had an extra
click anomie oh absolutely
hey listen please I'm not chucking bombs
in their old-school camera not doing as
its told it's my voice it's my other
homeschool camera
mm-hmm-hmm oh nice slides no soul amber
twitchy you mean yeah yeah my pc
masterrace now watch what you and I play
like something fast like oh watch bar
kombi touching this okay am i selling a
big crate better give me some big points
ow
ha hey boxes physics is free got any of
you look box ah rude what's in the box
you got three and a half minutes left
over at a time
[Music]
there we go don't fall out
now you get you get chicken Gucci I'm
don't think I'm gonna get the corpse oh
really what up you know it doesn't
really you know it's not very nice for
her is it
oh no no time I'd want to go back in the
ground okay so get back there is it you
get back you're gonna be recycled into
someone's niro Maude I want to get my um
get my ashes turned into a fake diamond
you know I made I made an error there I
mixed it yeah Rose yeah I did the same
thing as you and dump our cycle judges
yeah I'm Mason and I share to look when
you did that I just baked thought up
again so that computer screen your car
got two and a half minutes left school
get in fold down
I don't chuck them in because you did
some weird gust of wind
oh yeah I'll do that
it's a very immersive reason it's stuff
chair the whole strategies list you get
big stuff you get small stuff um just
plug just not gonna do
I don't know Mike might be oh my god I
thought this box at Activision on it
ascension shipping curve not there you
go
yeah merit actually load it eventually
get out of it
get out great film yes you wouldn't know
I'm soon cuz you're the only person in
the office I wasn't seen get out I'm
stuck again
so much on though my weird sign it's
gone shot torch okay 1/2 minutes left
no I got much more space you know I've
not got a lot of space left let's go for
tiny things
we'll get there slowly get there slowly
one box at a time no rush you got a
minute left
don't Oh
Activision please again sphere whoa
get in the sphere oh sorry if I take
your files
that's gotta give me something I'm
really tempted to put one of the
explosive cylinders in there hmm
but at least learn from one of those
things
you almost didn't learn from go on
either no get a nice mirror I play I
play microphone once well I'm very tired
in my boyfriend you up there you are
less than 30 seconds oh she got 20
seconds alright you give me a
five-second countdown
no well house will I know Oh wheeler no
not up it's an arrow we're in the in the
um shelving unit eggs a goose is fine
it's fine
five four three two go on oh I got it in
all right seems a shame but don't stay
I'm staying
okay oh god my phone's crashed okay its
back
stay in stay in stay in stay in Stan oh
I have a feeling that I've lost this one
I don't know cuz what the hell ah
I wondered what happen that ha ha ha I
thought I was close
see I don't know cuz you didn't recycle
all of your stuff no some of it it
turned into spare parts I don't I don't
know if it needs to get all the way into
the middle mmm but oh it's not looking
good
oh it's not looking good it didn't
recycle nearly any of it some lip
oh um interesting okay
trashing the place I'll take it
take all take the bed all my bits having
everything I wasn't recycling that's
right poopy skin was this yo you another
wrench out of it I had that I think it's
my original wrench okay that looks like
everything
are you caused an eyesore fire here get
your glue gun oh we can't retitled it I
think I actually did whistle yeah you
did good
all right let's see what we've got
assume you've got I don't know of some
things less of others
nice we're gonna have to go into the
post-processing and count Matt I think
well I want you guys at home to do is I
want you to try the challenge go to this
place give yourself five minutes and
then leave in the comment section below
how much raw materials you actually
brought savored recycled and I'm going
to I'm going to make like a nice little
ending screen to show the final scores
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
the like button subscribe to GameSpot
for the Deaf and stuff like this and for
more hot prey content if you want to see
our review then you can go check that
out too more did a lovely job on that
until then it's goodbye from me and
goodbye from Lucy it's goodbye from him
good night
goodbye